to wrap us up for the evening please
welcome our Executive Vice President of
impact and inclusion Janelle English
thank you Joan
raise this a bit
as this fantastic evening draws to a
close I again have to say thank you to
some more individuals who made it all
possible I want to thank our incredible
director Barbara stapanski
come get your flowers Barbara yes
the distinctive voices of Keiko aguina
Monica Barbaro logic D Collins and
Dorian Mystic
I was a fan of each of them before
tonight but I'm officially joining their
fan club so I hope you join me with that
um and I of course want to offer my
sincerest gratitude to the academy
nickel fellowships and screenwriting
team Joan who you just met Chris Alex
this program would truly not be possible
without you your commitment is it's
inspiring so thank you
[Applause]
I'd also like to give a special note of
love and appreciation to the nickel
fellowships and screenwriting committee
chaired by Academy Award nominee Eric
Heiser
[Applause]
their leadership and energy guided the
2022 screenwriting competition to this
moment of culmination and celebration
I'd also introduce you to tonight's
award presenter an academy gold intern
Kenny Beckford
thank you all
as the Academy's Executive Vice
President of impact and inclusion I am a
deep believer in the power of the nickel
fellowships
why because I'm a deep believer in the
power of Storytelling a good story can
make one person laugh or light up a
crowd it can give voice to a community
it can stimulate necessary conversation
it can speak the truth
of a town a city
a nation
it can facilitate progress
it can change the world
The Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences is Mission driven to help break
down barriers so that everyone has the
best chance of success and can
participate in this incredible art form
that we know and love to their fullest
potential
to help fulfill this Mission the
Academy's Talent Development programs of
which the nickel fellowships is a
Cornerstone were born
in total the nickel and her sister
programs the Student Academy Awards gold
Rising the gold Fellowship for women the
Jonas guangwa film music initiative and
the Academy film accelerator recognized
that there is so much progress to be
made to realize full opportunity and
access in our industry
these programs they're not charity they
are a critical investment in the future
of this industry which will only
continue to thrive from greater
diversity and representation
as such
proud of that Bart
as such the nickel fellowships in
screenwriting program through the
passion and dedication of its diverse
community of fellows
of the six new fellows championed here
tonight amounts to an ongoing Narrative
of not merely imagining progress
but making the best most inclusive
future a reality for all
I want to thank you all for joining us
tonight in this celebration in this
moment and I wish you a good no a great
night so thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you